[موسيقى]
بقراءه
جريئه تتجاوز المحظور على واقع اغنيه
محظوره
صغيره
[تصفيق]
وقوانين الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
انهم ابناء ما يعرف بالجيل زد من الشباب
الذين شكلوا عماد الاحتجاجات الاخيره في
ايران ولد في اواخر التسعينيات ومع مطلع
القرن الحادي والعشرين باتو يشكرون اليوم
احد تحديات البلاد في مرحله الاحتجاجات
وما بعدها تقول ارقام مركز الاحصاء الرسمي
انهم يتجاوزون 15 مليون شخص ما دفع اوساطا
سياسيه لترفيهم جيلا قادرا على وضع البلاد
على حافه مازق امنيا وسياسين واجتماعي
من هو هذا الجيل وماذا يريد نقترب منه
لنتعرف كيف يفكر وبما يطالب يقول هؤلاء ان
اسلوب الحياه هو خيارهم هوم لا خيار
السلطات سقف مطالبهم مرتفع يصل حد
المطالبه بتغيير نظام الحكم في البلاد لكن
دون طرح اي بدائل واضحه كما انهم يفتقرون
لاي قياده منظمه لذلك يوصفون بانهم جيل
الانترنت
والمجتمع الافتراضي
بما يلبي مطالب اغلبيه المجتمع ويحافظ على
وحدته
الضغط الذي مرسى على المراه ادى الى
امتلاكها القدره والجراه لتقود العديد من
التجمعات يقف المجتمع الايراني اليوم بين
جيلين الاول ولد ليجد نفسه في جمهوريه
اسلاميه
والاخر صوت لها مطلع 800 القرن الماضي
يتفق الاثنين في كثير من المطالب وبين ما
اختار الجيل زد التعبير عنها بصوت مرتفع
فان الجيل الذي سبق يبدو اكثر هدوءه محمد
عايش الثوره قبل نحو اربعه عقود هو صاحبه
كشك لبيع الصحفي بطيران يتابع اخبار
الاحتجاجات ويرى ان النظام قابل للاصلاح
من الداخل
الاجيال يجب القيام ببعض التغييرات لان
الانهيار خطير ولا نريد تكرار ما حدث في
دول بالمنطقه
ما بين جيل قديم كبر على القيم وعبر عن
اعتراضه غالبا بشكل مدني وجيل جديد غير
مرتبط كثيرا بالثقافه التقليديه
ومستعد للمغامره تقول السلطات انها تتفهم
مطالب التغيير لكنها ترفض كليا منتصفهم
بمثيري الشغب من الاجيال الشابه وتتخذ
اجراءات صارمه تبدا بتقيد الوصول الى
الانترنت وحظر بعض وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وصولا الى الاعتقالات والسجن
واصدار الاحكام بالاعدام على من تتهممهم
بالافساد في الارض فيما يدعو خبراء
الاجتماع الى استبدالها هذه الشده باللين
والاحتواء
لا يتقنون
هذا الجيل فطالما تجاهلوه كما ان هذا
الجيل لا يفهم لغه النظام والافضل اليوم
فتح حوار معه في المدارس جامعات وحتى على
منصات التواصل
رجعوا احتجاجات الجيلي زد في الفضاء
الحقيقي لكن منشوراتهم في الفضاء
الافتراضي تؤكد انهم مستعدون للعوده الى
الشارع مجددا
والمطالبه بما يرونه حقا لهم في التعبير
والتغيير عمر هواش الجزيره طيران